we're the Transportation Security  Administration we're working hard to  ensure that you enjoy a secure flight  and while we cannot apprehend every  terrorist you can count on us to do what  we are trained to do whenever there's a  security breach overreact to tiny  threats when a man walked the wrong way  through a gate at Newark Airport we  closed the terminal for six hours when a  passenger in Bakersfield California  packed honey in his luggage we shut the  whole airport down and when a toddler in  New Orleans tried to take a Christmas  present on board we confiscated it sorry  Junior we're not taking any chances  no threat is too big for us to ignore  and no threat is too small for us to  make your travel experience as miserable  as possible over react to small threats  ignore the big ones that's what we do  and we do it better than anyone